mit ihrem einsatz bewegen mehr kultur
swisslos wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
[Musik]
es gibt gute gründe wütend zu sein
in der kunstwelt haben es frauen nach
wie vor schwer
auch wenn es heute große
einzelausstellungen von frauen gibt die
museumsdepots sind voll von männern
in ihrer sammlung geht es im kunstmuseum
basel sind frauen
kulturplatz über den langen weg zur
gleichstellung in der kunst
[Musik]
wir kommen nach dem kulturplatz ja wir
sind heute im kunsthaus zürich wo
aktuell das werk von yoko ono zu sehen
ist eine vorreiterin der feministischen
kunst das schauen wir uns gleich an und
wir fragen vor allem auch wo sind
eigentlich die frauen im kunstbetrieb
[Musik]
fc la femme denn noch immer sind es die
männer die den kunstbetrieb dominieren
ganz egal ob als direktorin kuratoren
oder aus kunstschaffende und dass das
ändert sich nur langsam wir wollen
herausfinden weshalb das so ist
[Musik]
der künstler mario bucher er verwaltet
den nachlass seiner mutter heidi bucher
eine künstlerin aus der 1970 er und 80
er jahren die lange unbekannt blieb
also das ist ja interessant
dokumentation oder dass da drei die
nazis auch vielleicht dass ich am
mannheimer ganz wichtige arbeit die wir
jetzt gar nicht hin in bayern zeigt also
wirklich dass ich einen besseren blick
in london das messobjekt weiß nicht mehr
wo das ist
bekannt wurde heidi bucher mit latex
abzügen von räumen aber erst 30 jahre
nach ihrem tod erhält sie ihre erste
große retrospektive im haus der kunst in
münchen
zu ihrer lebzeit wurde ihre kunst
ignoriert
[Musik]
vergessen wir sind dazu aus dass
afghanistan europas sieht das sind
männer mit bei dass ich kriege es
langsam aber ein mitwisser bert oder
macht sie so einfach frauen
greift gehört und dass ich über alles
kann heidi hat eigentlich nur ein
vorteil insofern dass sie
als einzelkind aus einer gutbürgerlichen
hintergrund und hat dem sind
existenziell sorge aber sich natürlich
gegen die wir viele eigentlich die
allermeisten andere frauen ihre zitate
unglaublich widerstanden ist bekannt
lange waren es die männer die sich mit
großen gesten durchsetzen konnten die
kleins blaue malerei
lange ließ explodierende maschine
[Musik]
jackson pollocks drip paintings und
natürlich gerhard richter
[Musik]
alles die ganz großen der
kunstgeschichte und alles männer
[Musik]
auf einem foto aus der 1980 er jahren
ist alles drauf was in der kunst in new
york rang und namen hatte
doch nur eine frau
mia westermann rosen die heute keiner
mehr kennt
[Musik]
die galerie hauser & wirth in zürich
die britische kuratorin tanja borssen
hat eine ausstellung eingerichtet mit
künstlerinnen der galerie
viele sind frauen die erst in den
letzten jahren karriere machten obwohl
sie schon jahrzehnte als künstlerinnen
arbeiten
ich habe mit künstlerinnen gearbeitet
die in den sechziger und siebziger
jahren in new york gearbeitet haben
ihnen wurde von galerien und kuratoren
gesagt dass sie nicht mit frauen
arbeiten und das war etwas was
akzeptiert wurde bis in die 1970 er
jahre sie hatten einfach nicht das
richtige geschlecht
wie viele galerien versucht hause und
wird über seine frauen positionen ins
programm aufzunehmen
wie geht ab disco eine rumänische
künstlerin die bis vor kurzem niemand
kannte die aber schon in den 60er jahren
kunst machte
wieso erst jetzt
verschiedene gründe manchmal ist es weil
sie im schatten standen manchmal weil
sie mehr zeit zu hause verbracht und
ihre kunst auch zuhause entstand
ich denke daran künstlerinnen wie marisa
märz die mit mario merz verheiratet war
er hatte eine öffentliche karriere aber
sie hat zu hause gearbeitet am
küchentisch in kleinen formaten und erst
kürzlich wurde ihr werk wiederentdeckt
und bekommt viel mehr prominenz
was damals unterging hat massive
auswirkungen auf heute so hatte eine von
swissinfo in auftrag gegebene studie
ergeben dass zwischen 2008 und 2018 bis
zu 90% ausstellungen an großen museen
von männern stammen
in den sammlungen der großen häuser die
mit viel steuermillionen unterstützt
werden ist der prozentsatz weiblicher
künstler noch tiefer
von den 50 am teuersten verkauften
kunstwerken auf dem kunstmarkt ist
keines von einer frau
und während die anzahl der schulabgänger
an schweizer kunstschulen sich was
geschlechter angeht die balance erhält
sind es danach die frauen die auf der
strecke bleiben
das
top-thema wo frau bearbeitet hat wir bei
mutterschaft geburt und ist nett foto
ist
die zürcher künstlerin elisabeth eberl
hat sich vertieft mit der gleichstellung
der geschlechter in der kunst befasst
etwa zehn jahren begann sie die
förderpraxis in der kunst genauer unter
die lupe zu nehmen
ein strom von
künstlerinnen vereinigung
geleitet
und hat einfach gemerkt bio s bewertet
sich vor allem frauen und ihre finger
hoch finanziert
werden folgen christa zeigt und die
diskrepanz hat mich interessieren und
dann sind mir alle web wert und resultat
schulwettbewerb über die tieflader und
irgendwann habe ich den taschenrechner
techno und das kantonale
kulturgütern und handwerk dass sie den
männern im durchschnitt doppelt so viel
zahlt sich doppelt so viel wert auf oder
männer und sie ganz spanien zu zwei
drittel
bei den öffentlich finanzierten museen
sieht es nicht besser aus sowohl bei den
sammlungen aber noch wichtiger bei den
großen einzelausstellungen sind die
männlichen künstler überproportional
vertreten die führung werden kaum ernst
genommen
und bin auch sachsens prozent auf 31
prozent männer und zum teil nur bis ins
20 jahrhundert
gestellt worden und das hat mich
schockiert weil sich sehr viel
staatliches garten und das hat mich
extrem umgedacht
eberle und andere frauen versuchen seit
jahren die offiziellen kulturfahrt werfe
die ungleichheit dem kunstbetrieb zu
sensibilisieren
erst in den letzten jahren trägt dies
früchte
das kunstmuseum in basel eines der
grössten der schweiz mit einer
jahrhunderte alten sammlung und einem
großen budget das museum hat in den
letzten jahren vermehrt frauen gezeigt
wie auch jetzt louise bourgeois doch das
ist neu
ich sage in ihrer sammlung geht es im
kunstmuseum basel sind frauen gab es
weniger witzig aber
das ist sehr sehr klein ich danke sobald
mehr noch ein zweiter war also ziemlich
vorwerk noch ein zweiter weltkrieg de
andratx
markant und jeden
amerikaner ward rund um so gut lief
louise bourgeois ist ein gutes beispiel
für eine künstlerin die schon in den
60er jahren bekannt war doch nicht ernst
genommen wurde
es ist
kriterien sind so aussieht als mann und
zum teil auch künstler muss man sagen
frauen einfach über halten die
tanzkinder das geht mir ja wieder lewis
bush waren meine der rotkohl und
der königin und audi lütow sich
persönlich könnte die intakte hat das
ist irgendwie
die ist das sicher nicht wichtig und ich
bin nicht
gut was die gemacht und ich danke den
blick hat sich wirklich geändert
und gesagt glaube ich
es nochmal das ist sehr wichtig
hätten kuratoren wie josef helfenstein
die in der kunstwelt den kanon
mitbestimmen das nicht ändern können
1,8
wagners märkten zeigt und dvs und
geschichte wo man dennoch nicht zeigt
ich finde einfach mal
damit wort die nicht sagen man hat es
besser machen natürlich haben es eben
besser machen aber ich glaube noch eine
geschichte leider nicht
kurz nach einer geschichte mit quasi
korrigieren was passiert ist passiert
was passiert ist ist passiert
das gilt auch für heidi bucher die lange
auf eine anerkennung warten musste
es ist friedlich
das noch verstanden hat angst vor wacker
oder hat er
für waffen bekannt ist das sind die
apotheker und das material textil latex
das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt bisher
sehr konventionell ist eine komische
kunst zum teil haben mit mit performance
mit aktionismus mit gesellschaftlichem
fokus so hätten fast was ich fast ein
bisschen entziehen
bislang
standen
heute werden buch aus latex werke von
den weltweit großen museen sowohl
ausgestellt wie auch gesammelt
[Musik]
also absolute zahlen von rassenkrieg des
vorjahres hat sich verzehnfacht
kommerziell war
auch wenn die preise von künstlerinnen
langsam anziehen vergleichbar mit den
männern sind sie noch lange nicht das
hat auch mit den galerien und den
mechanismen des marktes zu tun
der
handelsstruktur so sind
um entwicklungen ist außerdem zwei
drittel nahmen in den meisten galerien
und ein drittel also durchschnittlich
ein drittel frauen
das preisgeld vor dem andern ist höher
als auf eine galerie ihre miete bezahle
dann im thema es ist ein kreatives und
die
sprache
ich einfach unglaublich schwierig frau
im grundstücks- und immer noch total
unterbewertet dass er weder g zu
vergleichen und das wird sich gar nicht
so schnell lernen der appell richtet
sich noch ein der markt ist angebot und
nachfrage und da ist einfach so dass
andy warhol und alle die die männer
künstler die diese unendlich hoch
bewertet und frauen verglichen ist
lächerlich wenig und da gibt es vor
allem viel weniger frauen oder wo auf
dem bekanntheitsgrad
foto stiftung zürich beim aufbau der
ausstellung der schweizer künstlerin
mahnung
sie schaut auf ein werk der letzten 50
jahre zurück
der ganz große erfolg ist auch ihr
bisher verwehrt geblieben
ja es ist gar nichts habe wenn es der
ausstellung diese
dieses motto gibt die ausstellung die
kommt zu spät
eine volle too late und lehre tablette
fleischlich und rot die große worte legt
das heißt er frau ist froh war aber
jetzt
wo das eine völlig andere platz ist
nämlich am anfang der ausstellung
ist die tablette weg
große geblieben und zulegt bezirk sich
ein gedicht auf dass die ausstellung
jetzt da und die und ständiger wonach
römer dass sie es läuft ja jetzt sehr
eigentlich zu sparen sind
auch wenn es nicht die karriere ist die
mahnung vorschwebte sie bleibt eine
vorreiterin der schweizer performance
kunst
es ist zu hoffen dass ihre werke die
anerkennung erhalten die sie schon
längst verdient haben
[Musik]
und erstaunliches mit der kuratorin der
ausstellung über die ökonomie um nadine
ist das sehen wir jetzt geht der ganze
stress werden uns auf jeden fall versagt
was hat das cut piece damals für
politiker und wähler hat es ist das
totale neues die sich so zeigt ein
vorläufer von der ganzen feministische
performance-kunst wonach aber muss sich
vorstellen dass das noch immer eine
theater stattfindet aus aller welt
natürlich brav auf jedem stuhl setzen
und da hat yoko ono sich alle künstler
auf die bühne und hatte glück seid
kümmert und schmiedet für mich leider
das stück hat einiges krise stock und
hut aufhaben haben sich ohne kleid und
so stand das publikum aktiv oder so
völlig bis neues wieso hat man sie
benötigt das frühere leben eine ganz
starke ums thema autismus khartums
stelle von weiblichen körpers entblößen
von ihren körper und eben hallo tante
gewalt gegenüber am körper und das sind
alles themen wonach er natürlich von
vielen künstlerinnen auch wieder
bearbeitet werden zur achten und ihre
diakonie hat einmal eine werbung
schaltet für die ausstellung effektive
ausstellung im museum of modern art in
new york als ein ort wo sie damals
niemals eine chance die
ausstellung ich so werde das unmöglich
so undankbar ja wohl damals wirklich
drei frauen eine große institutionen die
einzelnen stellige über holland wo sie
eigentlich für die ntt hat sie auch
selbst einbringen
konzeptuell jungs stelle gemacht und
hatte geschaltet im village voice und im
ort forum und hat immer gesagt wo dann
bis dann gibt es die one woman show im
monat und lustige wie hat sie das
plakat mit dem großen
vor mit dem iphone und heidloff also
dass sich der name vom museum of modern
art im museum model
verhandelt hat gesagt es gibt zwei es
hat damals weniger und stelle gegenüber
frauen zweier künstlerinnen das bis hin
zu audio im kunsthaus zürich warum ist
das immer noch so
mit der aktion vor dem thron ja das hat
sich auch zum glück also in den letzten
jahren so dass ich hab es bewegt aber
das hat halt einfach mit einem ähnlich
trägt
liegt sowohl kunstgeschichte projekt hat
geschrieben hat und womit csu sprachen
und eben auch die frauen für die un
werden zeigen wie yoko ono die dir diese
wichtige figur sie für die geschichte im
20 jahrhundert haben die das programm
spezifisch für frauen mit wirklicher
wandel
es ist jetzt wirklich mit seiner frau
ist spiele der wichtige polizei
programmlich deutlich fiel da werden
viel mehr frauen zeigen und
zu machen und sich wieder in
kunstgeschichte zu recherchieren und
positionen wo wir bis jetzt
vernachlässigt hat gerade die sammlung
ist es ja sehr massiv aus sicht berlins
prozent war vom andere tradition spieler
sagen
und weil in den nächsten fünf jahren nur
noch weibliche kunst auch auf wird das
sie machen ja also ich war persönlich
wie so eine aktion zu aber ich bin ein
stilles im kuratorium unter direktion
und
direktion mit dem blaulicht eher schmale
frau als direktorin vor dem haus in 102
jahren kriegsgeschichte dass ich ja
schon auch wirklich freue ich mich sehr
drauf dass das so ist und mitte jahr
über mit denen mit einer frau wo jetzt
die position die namen von direktoren
verschiedene museen das ist
[Musik]
angst schmerz und wut aus diesen
emotionen näherte sich das künstlerische
schaffen der julis bush war die
französin mit amerikanischen wurzeln
wurde jahrzehntelang aus künstlerin
ignoriert bevor sie zu einer der
wichtigsten figuren des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts wurde nun nimmt sich eine
andere große künstlerin dem schaffen von
louis bush war an und zwar die us
amerikanerin jenny holzer
frauen haben einen schweren stand in der
gesellschaft warum sollte es in der
kunstwelt anders sein
ich reiste in die hölle und zurück und
lass mich dir sagen es war wundervoll
louis bush war hat ihren schmerz ihre
angst und ihre wut in ihre kunst gepackt
persönlich rätselhaft und verstörend
schmerz ist mein geschäft
jenny holzer hat diesen schmerz und die
wut vor allem in louis bush war es
sprache gefunden und eine ausstellung
daraus gemacht
angst treibt die welt an das ist ganz
schön passend oder
diese barbie puppe hat einen schlechten
tag
dieses gefällt mir sehr
das ist ein erstaunliches werk es ist
ein weibliches werk würde ich sagen eine
manifestation des frauen problems
louis bursch war war gefangen in ihrer
rolle als hausfrau und dreifache mutter
und getrieben vom drang sich in der
kunst zu befreien ein schmerzhaftes
dilemma dass holzer selber mutter einer
tochter sichtbar machen wollte
bush war ein großes vorbild für
künstlerinnen
sie war suizidal und sie hat sich nicht
umgebracht
sie hat die bestmögliche arbeit gemacht
und durchgehalten
bush war arbeitete lange zeit unbeachtet
von der kunstwelt allein in ihrem
kämmerlein
[Musik]
es ist eine binsenwahrheit aber es ist
wahr dass frauen spät erfolg haben wenn
überhaupt
wir sind oft zu beschäftigt dreckige
arbeiten zu erledigen
und finden dann eben weder zeit noch
raum kreativ zu sein
ich heiße luise josephin busch ich bin
am 24 dezember 1911 in paris geboren
einer meiner werke der letzten 50 jahre
haben ihre wurzeln in meiner kindheit
mein vater war ein ziemlich
erfolgreicher mann und von großer
selbstzufriedenheit
ein leben lang versuchte bush war mit
ihrer kunst die verletzungen aus ihrer
kindheit zu überwinden
der vater hatte vor aller augen eine
affäre mit dem kindermädchen und wurde
zur hassfigur er lehnte die tochter ab
und ließ sie das deutlich spüren
[Musik]
er machte sich lustig über mich mit
seinen bösartigen humor
ich konnte mich nicht verständlich
machen und konnte ihm nicht antworten
in louis bush war schauriger
installation die zerstörung des vaters
wirft sie ihm der familie zum fraß vor
[Musik]
diese installation ist voller schrecken
und hat auch ein kleines bisschen humor
damit man die angst überlebt das thema
ist der kampf mit ihrem vater
ihre geliebte mutter starb früh ihr
widmete sie ihre berühmteste figur die
über große spinne
sie ist die beschützerin vor allem bösen
die zentrale rolle der frau in der welt
das hat louis bursch war umgetrieben
die stofflichkeit ist zentral und
wortwörtlich der faden
beachten sie das kleine tier voller
stacheln da geht es uns berührt uns
nicht berührt werden
um verletzungen durch berührungen sie
ist niemals eindeutig
sie hatte eine wundervolle hand und
einen großartigen geist und sie konnte
nicht schlafen und nicht aufhören zu
arbeiten
das wollte ich zeigen
jenny holzer arbeitet mit bush war
texten auch außerhalb des kunstmuseums
sie projiziert zitate auf wichtige
gebäude in basel
eine frau zu sein ist gefährlich in
meinen skulpturen ausgedrückt durch
penis speerspitze messer schwert wort
flüsse im öffentlichen raum das ist
jenny holzers kunstform ihr medium
pulsierende led leuchtbändern für ihre
politischen provokanten und
feministischen botschaften ist sie seit
den 1980 er jahren berühmt beschützt
mich vor meinen wünschen
geld bildet den geschmack erzieher
mädchen und jungs auf die gleiche weise
machtmissbrauch ist keine überraschung
da wo frauen sterben bin ich hellwach
im gegensatz zu louis bursch war ist
jenny holzer sehr früh erfolgreich
1990 bespielte sie als erste frau den
amerikanischen pavillon an der biennale
in venedig und gewann den goldenen löwen
eine sensation
heute beleuchten ihre wortkaskaden die
bedeutendsten museen der welt
louis bush war hingegen erhielt erst mit
über 70 jahren weltweite aufmerksamkeit
und wertschätzung
obwohl sie ihr leben lang unaufhörlich
kunst machte taucht ihr name in männlich
dominierten kunstbetrieb kaum je auf das
änderte sich erst 1982 mit einer großen
retrospektive im museum of modern art in
new york
männer sind keineswegs anti
feministische ignorieren die frauen
einfach im grunde hat es mir geholfen
dass man mich so lange ignoriert hat
dadurch konnte ich mich auf mich selbst
konzentrieren
das persönliche ist politisch und
relevant und doch ist es für frauen
schwieriger ernst genommen zu werden
jetzt ist die stunde der rache
ich denke frauen müssen immer noch
zahlen für ihren erfolg die leute sind
mit ihnen irgendwie kritischer
mister nein danke
[Musik]
so wird man verstanden
ich bin nicht immer ein wildes beast
aber ich bin es von zeit zu zeit
[Musik]
alexander wrabetz ist während in einer
woche ausstellungseröffnung im kunsthaus
zürich quasi parallel zu der yoko ono
dass ich immer noch nix verständlich
dass man aus frau eine einzelausstellung
berühmt in großzügigem ist das nicht ein
verein habe tragische frauen heutzutage
andere frage stellt aus frage der
zuständigkeit will man eigentlich im
zeitalter vor
der kriminelle strukturen sind und
die tdh eigentlich die frage nicht ahnt
dass colin relevant sie zeigen die
darsteller performance wirklich ist ganz
klar der körper ist politisch wie yoko
ono war vor sechs jahren das heißt es
augen sind ein sport nicht so viel wie
ich
danke allen dass es vielleicht auch
heißt dass gewisse zeitlos sind und
große thema sich halt wirklich auf der k
publiziert und dass der körper immer
noch relevant die schützen
ich denke das hat sich sehr viel
verändert
in bezug auf sichtbarkeit von zehn
stimmen in der politik an die
verschiedenen strukturen das muss man
schon aussagen aber vielleicht sind die
patriarchale strukturen einfach noch
nicht gesprochen und auch bietet sie
eine sichtbarkeit gesehen für positionen
rohstoffe stehen sind frauen
logisch ist
aber auch im fördersystem zum beispiel
wir sind sie da sind sich auch für
erfahrung gemacht dass kunststoffen in
bezug auf das ist eben danke ich
das nicht stimmt eingeholt worden sind
aber ich bin wirklich große
unterstützung bisher dankbar dafür aber
ich denke dass die strukturen
ausgerichtet sind so mancher wirklich zu
diana familie hans oder gleichzeitig
einfach aus strengen die karriere hand
wo jene sitzformen 1 2 funktionieren das
heißt die hand wird immer noch kein
system
nachhaltig irgendwie mit caritas
unterstützt mit familie wo am wochenende
schaffte wurde wegen scharfer und so
weiter das hat der stadtteil sind nicht
ganz in der balance oder das heißt sie
sich immer noch ein großer spagat man
muss nicht angewiesen auf private
persönliche strom und funktionierenden
mit einer eigentlich schaffen
st
hier draußen im garten des kunsthaus
zürich steht der mystery von yoko ono da
kann man seine wünsche ihnen hängen und
wir halten es mit einem slogan von yoko
ono selbst die effizienz
und ansonsten freuen wir uns auf ein
weibliches kunst jahr 20 22 zb heidi
bucher im kunstmuseum bern oder waren im
herbst hier in zürich wieder niki de
saint phalle nächste woche ergründen wie
ihr das erfolgsgeheimnis von walt disney
denn der konzern ist aktuell mit 23
oscar nominationen im rennen und gleich
jetzt folgt ihr auf sf1 die sternstunde
philosophie meine kollegin barbara
bleisch unterhält sich mit der
türkischen schriftstellerin ehrlicher
keine gute woche für sie
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
tourismus
[Musik]